bertrand badie notre grand entretien ce
soir politologue professeur émérite à
sciences po paris spécialiste des
questions internationales vous avez
participé à l'écriture d'un livre du
collectif regards dessine moi un
pangolin votre chapitre avoue sans
titulaire regarder la sécurité globale
en face et puis vous publier très
prochainement le 1er octobre prochain
inter socialité le monde n'est plus
géopolitique merci infiniment d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
le liban est en train de se reconstruire
mais il doit le faire avec une
population qui change ce qui le peuvent
et c'est de partir si ce qu'on vient de
voir aussi dans ce reportage quelles
conséquences cela peut avoir sur le plan
évidemment sociologique mais du coup
politique
eh bien vous aime fait l'amabilité de
citer le livre que je vais sortir c'est
exactement ça c'est à dire nous vivons
une révolution impressionnante pour
surtout pour celles et ceux comme moi
qui ont vécu la guerre froide qui était
hyper politique où finalement le sort du
monde se décider entre gouvernements
dans leurs affrontements ou dans leur
coopération et parfois leur connivence
maintenant le politique est comme huer
désarmé impotent je dirais un certain
point de vue et ce sont les dynamiques
sociales qui mène le monde
le cas du liban on va en parler est tout
à fait remarquable
mais c'est vrai également pour tout ce
qu'on a vu en amérique latine tout au
long de l'année 2019
c'est vrai aussi en france d'un certain
point de vue c'est vrai également en
afrique ce qui se passe au liban est
effectivement tout à fait remarquable
c'est à dire des ressorts politiques
casser une incapacité du système
politique de réagir autrement qu'en
continuant de la même façon regarder ce
changement de premier ministre qui
devait marquer la rupture
et voilà la nomination d'un homme qui
est le pur fruit du sérail ce qui veut
dire quoi
eh bien ça veut dire que le politique ne
réagit plus les manettes politiques ne
réagissent plus quand les manettes
politiques ne réagissent plus eh bien ce
sont les dynamiques sociales qui
prennent le relais et la grande inconnue
sur le plan politique c'est de savoir si
ces dynamiques sociales vont avoir un
transformateur politique qui leur
permettra de réaliser construire un
changement institutionnel en reste et ça
peut profiter au hezbollah
par exemple le hezbollah fait partie du
système politique libanais d'ailleurs
c'est extrêmement intéressant parce
qu'il s'est formée à l'extérieur du
système politique libanais et c'est pour
ça qu'il a eue dès le départ se profile
2010 qui opposait son extériorité par
rapport aux institutions libanaises et
peu à peu il a été absorbé par ce
système politique libanais et donc il
est en difficulté on l'a vu il a été
accroché dans les rues dans les
manifestations le problème est
véritablement là c'est à dire que
peut-on faire
lorsque les sociétés réclame non pas un
changement de politique non pas un
changement de personnel non pas un
changement de gouvernement
voir d'institutions mais un changement
de système on entendait ça dans les rues
de beyrouth
tous les jours on veut changer le
système on l'entendait dans les rues
d'alger
on l'entendait même dans les rues de
paris dans la bouche des gilles et jo je
voudrais vous montrer cette triste image
du jour au liban qui a fait le tour
évidemment des réseaux sociaux et de
toutes les télévisions un mois après la
double explosion c'est un énorme
incendie regarder qui s'est déclaré sur
le port de beyrouth déjà complètement
dévastée l'essayiste qu'on connaît bien
ici sur public sénat franco libanais jad
zaba tweet est ce si cet incendie est la
triste allégorie de l'incapacité
répétées de la classe politique
libanaise et de l'état à assurer ses
missions au premier rang desquels
protection et sécurité
c'est exactement cela sert on ne peut
pas mieux formuler la situation actuelle
vous savez faisons un petit peu
d'histoire très rapide malaisie pour soi
l'état qu'ils étaient inventées partout
dans le monde pas seulement au liban il
a été inventé pour assurer la protection
des populations qui sont sous son
gouvernement
à partir du moment où cette fonction de
protection n'est pas assurée on est dans
une situation de rupture de ce fameux
contrat social qui a fondé l'état et la
difficulté qui est propre liban c'est
que non seulement cet état n'est plus en
mesure d'assurer les fonctions
essentielles d'un état donc n'est plus
crédible n'a plus la confiance n'a plus
de légitimité mais en plus
il faut s'interroger sur la manière dont
il y a maintenant 100 ans on a célébré
le centenaire de la proclamation du
grand liban ce cet état a été construit
il a été construit sur des bases qui
sont des bases communautaires à partir
d'un pari pratiquement impossible dont
on ne trouve de réussite nulle part dans
l'histoire du monde qui est
d'institutionnaliser les communautés
pour en faire la base d'un système
politique
ce système s'est lézardé au fil des
années et des décennies maintenant il
s'est effondré et du coup le problème
est double
c'est à dire que peut-on faire quand il
n'ya plus d'état parce que d'un certain
point de vue il n'ya pas d'état et que
peut-on faire
lorsque le modèle d'état qui a
fonctionné plus ou moins bien pendant
100 ans n'était pas véritablement adapté
à la réalité sociologique de la
population libanaise
l'autre sujet de préoccupation bertrand
badie de la france et de l'europe c'est
la turquie ankara faisait partie des
dossiers abordés lors du sommet des pays
du sud de l'union européenne tout à
l'heure le président français a eu un
discours assez clair assez tranchants
même sur air doan écoutez nous devons
nous européens être clair et ferme avec
non pas la turquie comme nation comme
peuple mais avec le gouvernement du
président erdogan qui aujourd'hui à des
comportement inadmissible des propos qui
ont fait immédiatement réagir la turquie
déclarations arrogantes à dire en car à
cet après midi et ce qu'il a raison
emmanuel macron est ce que la turquie
n'est plus un partenaire alors c'est
très compliqué comme situation il faut
ce ne pas se précipiter sur des formules
définitives la turquie présente je
dirais deux caractéristiques majeures
l'une génétique
c'était un empire et se pose un énorme
problème qui n'est pas propre à la
turquie comment peut-on passer d'un
empire à un état cela provoque partout
des drames que ce soit l' empire russe
que ce soit lempire chinois que ce soit
l' empire ottoman à chaque fois on rêve
encore verdone oui d'un certain point de
vue et ça m'amène au deuxième paramètre
c'est que la turquie
ce n'est pas rien par le nombre
d'habitants par la position géographique
de ce pays de par son économie de par le
fait qu'elle est un pont presque
naturelle entre l'asie et l'europe et
peut-être le monde chrétien et le monde
musulman est en situation d'être une
puissance régionale et ça c'est le drame
des relations internationales actuelles
depuis la chute du mur où il n'y avait
que deux puissances qui comptait
poussent un peu partout des puissances
régionales qui veulent être reconnus
comme tels et la souffrance de la tuerie
comme de l'iran qui n'est pas loin c'est
cette ce refus opposé par la communauté
internationale de reconnaître un statut
à la turquie de la reconnaître comme
puissance régionale
alors quand on ne veut pas reconnaître
quelqu'un ce quelqu'un réagi par
l'outrance vous justifiez presque le la
politique expansionniste d'ardoyne je ne
justifie pas au contraire je dis que
c'est une pathologie qui conduit à une
autre pathologie
je dis qu'effectivement on n'a pas su
parler à la turquie on n'a pas su
intégrer la turquie dans l'union
européenne elle a attendu à la porte
pendant plus de 50 ans dans le système
international et que cette humiliation
constante qui a été opposé à la turquie
comme à d'autres pays voisins ou ou plus
lointain a mécaniquement enclencher un
système qui est dangereux voyez qu'il
n'y a pas de justification dans mon
propos qui est un système populisme une
passe derrière rien de tel que le
populisme pour récupérer cette
frustration et ce ressentiment et pour
pouvoir en quelque sorte en faire la
source d'une nouvelle dynamique
politique d'année aux nationalistes qui
est éclatant et puis ce pari d'erdogan
de celui qui a été son conseiller puis
sont mais ils affaires étrangères puis
son premier ministre avec lequel il
s'est fâché
davutoglu qui était de renouer avec ce
passé ottoman
je pense que c'est dangereux pour un
état
de se sortir des difficultés auxquelles
il est confronté en renouant avec un
passé qui est devenu mythique est
illusoire et surtout lorsque ce passé
est agressif pour ses voisins
mais alors comment régler cette
situation que devrait faire emmanuel
macron que devrait faire l'europe
quelles sont ces moyens de pression face
à air doan qui menacent notamment aussi
en appuyant sur le levier des migrants
par exemple vous savez il ya en
relations internationales me semble-t-il
deux mots clés qui sont intégration et
reconnaissance reconnaître l'autre nous
ne savons pas le faire
il y a qu'en petite mousse et l'europe
la france qui sait le vieux monde
c'est le vieux monde qui a été aux
commandes du système international
pendant des siècles et des siècles et
ceci finalement jusqu'à la
décolonisation et surtout jusqu'à la
chute du mur de berlin
avec la chute du mur de berlin ce temps
était terminée nous sommes entrés en
plein dans la mondialisation comprenons
cela s'est d'ailleurs nous ne sommes
plus dans l'europe du congrès de vienne
dans l'europe de 1914 ni même dans
l'europe de 1989 nous sommes dans la
mondialisation ça implique de
reconnaître l'autre qui appartient à une
autre histoire qui a sur sa région une
volonté d'être un acteur majeur
donnons lui cette chance quand nous lui
donnons pas eh bien il fait des choses
mauvaises dangereuse condamnable la
répression des kurdes va tout à fait
dans ce sens l'intervention sur le sol
syrien de la turquie va tout à fait dans
ce jeu dangereux avec la libye et oui
alors le jeu dangereux avec libye 1 vous
avez raison ça fait partie de ce rêve
impérial turc
mais attention c'est pas le seul que
celui qui n'a pas pêché en matière
libyenne se jette la première pierre
vous pensez à la france évidemment au
mais pas seulement je pense à la france
de monsieur sarkozy il monsieur bernard
henri lévy nous sommes en en 2011
et puis de ses successeurs mais je pense
à la grande bretagne qui était aussi
dans l'opération 2011 je pense aux états
unis et je pense surtout aujourd'hui à
des états extrêmement actif en libye
dans le conflit libye
que sont le voisin égyptien le maréchal
6,6 et plus loin
les émirats arabes unis la turquie est
un élément d'un jeu qui encore une fois
est régionalisé est là aussi pour le
compliquer davantage inter nationaliser
donc un intégration reconnaissance et
intégration intégration ça veut dire
quoi
ça veut dire que dans ce concert mondial
193 états souverains et combien d'autres
entités qui ne demande qu'à s'exprimer
eh bien il faut donner à chacun un rôle
qu'ils puissent contribuer à la
stabilisation internationale
si vous dites moi je fais tout c'est à
dire c'est moi qui définit l'ordre
international
c'est moi qui vais vous imposer des
règles c'est moi qui vais dire qui a
raison et qui a tort
c'est moi qui va dire où est le bien et
où est le mal vous créer une dynamique
conflictuelle qui hélas ne c'est un
drame donc exclure la turquie de l'otan
serait totalement contre-productif selon
moi je pense que c'est l'otan qui est
contre productive parce que justement en
fonction de ce que j'ai essayé de vous
montrer ses alliances n'ont plus de sens
l'otan appartient au système bipolaire
qui n'existe plus depuis 31 ans
et donc on est en porte à faux les
alliances mêmes sont en porte-à-faux
avez vous remarqué à quel point les
relations internationales sont davantage
dominée par la fluidité que par
l'alliance
c'est à dire que regarder les principaux
conflits
vous verrez que le positionnement de
chacun des acteurs changent en fonction
des scénarios
autrefois c'est très simple l'ami de mon
amie c'était mon ami l'ennemi de mon
ennemi
c'était également mon ami l'ami de mon
ennemi c'était mon ennemi est l'ennemi
de mon ami c'était mon ami basse et puis
si vous a subi mais on comprend l'idée
il ya un troisième dossier international
dans lequel la france joue un rôle
majeur c'est le mali je fais un petit
rappel historique pour nos
téléspectateurs en 2013 la france de
françois hollande intervient
militairement pour stopper l'avancée des
djihadistes et l'opération serval devenu
ensuite l'opération barkan pour
sécuriser la bande sahélo saharienne et
empêcher la reconstitution de
sanctuaires terroristes ça va
fonctionner au début vous me direz ce
que vous en pensez
et puis la situation va se compliquer
pour les troupes françaises jusqu'à
provoquer un sentiment
français local très fort depuis 2013 la
france a perdu 45 de ses soldats et sur
place la situation politique est
extrêmement instable on le sait coup
d'état militaire exit keita qu'est-ce
qu'on a ratées bertrand badie ce qu'on a
raté ses la lecture de ce conflit et ça
vous mettez là le doigt sur quelque
chose d'essentiel dans les relations
internationales d'aujourd'hui
c'est-à-dire qu'on continue à regarder
le monde d'aujourd'hui avec les lunettes
d'hier ne croire que les guerres
d'aujourd'hui sont le prolongement la
copie la reproduction des guerres d'hier
les guerres d'hier qu'est ce que c'était
s'était des affrontements de puissance
des compétitions de puissance
aujourd'hui les conflits qu'est ce que
c'est ce sont des compétitions de
faiblesse c'est à dire là où les états
se défont où les sociétés se décompose
où les économies sont complètement
incongrues improductif hier la guerre
c'était désarmer l'une face à l'autre ou
les une face aux autres
aujourd'hui la guerre ce sont les civils
surtout et si vous voulez être protégés
mieux vaut être militaire aujourd'hui
que civil autrefois la guerre c'était
des ambitions des stratégies
aujourd'hui les conflits ce sont des
phénomènes de décomposition le conflit
sahélien bien sûr y ait des djihadistes
médias disent c'est facile à trouver et
c'est facile à identifier affiché mais
le fondement même non pas du conflit
malien mais il faut dire aujourd'hui du
conflit sahélien parce que c'est un
conflit qui recouvre 5 million de
kilomètres carrés environ
bon le fondement de ce conflit c'est
quoi et bien c'est une imbrication de
facteurs écologiques sociaux culturels
et économiques qui sont terriblement
négatif pensait que dans le sahel
désertification progresse de 10 cm par
heure le temps de notre émission il ya
déjà 5 cm de plus de désertification
dans le sahel
ce qui veut dire quoi les cultivateurs
n'ont pu terre à cultiver et les
pasteurs non plus de fourrage pour leurs
troupeaux et donc viennent sur les
terres des cultivateurs qui déjà ne
peuvent pas s'en sortir
et tout ceci se mêlent où s'expriment à
travers des conflits intercommunautaires
le terrorisme là dedans
n'est qu'un épiphénomène c'est à dire
des entrepreneurs de violence qui
essayent de tirer profit de cette
situation hyper compliqué mais
suffisamment peur à la france pour
qu'elle intervienne en 2013 c'était donc
une erreur c'était une mauvaise manière
de d'aborder le problème sans ring oui
c'était une erreur parce que parce que
ce n'est pas une nouvelle bataille de la
marne qui va régler la question
sahélienne c'est beaucoup plus compliqué
que ça nous sommes dans la
mondialisation et la mondialisation fait
entrer dans le système international des
sociétés qui sont absolument invivable
et tant qu'elles sont invivables
cela se traduira par des explosions
conflictuelles et des explosions de
violence sans cesse plus forte et une
armée ne peut rien une armée peu contre
une autre armée dans les armées ne peut
rien contre des lambeaux mais non mais
exactement le contraire
il faut transformer ces sociétés
l'urgence l'urgence immédiate
c'est effectivement un plan de sauvetage
pour le sahel sans quoi il sera terreau
de violence et de conflits de manière
permanente et quand je disais tout à
l'heure que le populisme profiter de la
frustration et de ressentiment je dirais
là que les entrepreneurs de violences
terroristes profitent des situations de
décomposition sociale par le raid
ingérence non pardon on parlerait
d'ingérence non si on lançait si
l'europe lancé un immense plan de
sauvetage pour le sel écoutées
lorsqu'elles et le plan marshall pour
l'europe je sais pas si on a parlé
d'ingérence mais maintenant nous avons
des institutions multilatérales il ne
faut pas les oublier et vous avez dans
le système onusien des agences
formidable programme des nations-unies
pour le développement notamment qui fait
un travail extraordinaire et qui peut
fort bien s'il en a le mandat
et les moyens donnés par les puissances
et les plus riches d'entreprendre ces
transformations qui sont absolument
indispensables sans quoi vous aurez
toujours dans ces pays qui sont en
décomposition sociale en faillite
économique en faillite institutionnel il
n'y a pas d'institution pour régler le
jeu social vous aurez cette situation de
violence et nos malheureux soldat
périront sur cette base mais n'oublions
jamais
aussi les humanitaires rappelez-vous ce
qui s'est passé au mois d'août à akure
c'est-à-dire au niger victime victime de
cette mauvaise lecture de ce que sont
les conflits aujourd'hui il est temps
d'enlever comme des anglo saxons le
coton que l'on a sur les yeux voir la
réalité de ces conflits je voudrais vous
dire un point de vue que j'ai trouvé
intéressant c'est celui de l'ancien
diplomate laurent bigot il a publié une
tribune dans le monde fin août et il
nous dit le drame de la france est
encore et toujours le déni face aux
réalités sahélienne pour lui le péché
originel de la france c'est d'avoir
laissé kidal aux groupes armés touareg
et je le cite je n'ai jamais compris la
fascination d'une partie de la dgse et
de l'armée française pour ces groupes
armés touareg qui prétendait être
disposé à lutter contre les groupes dits
djihadistes en échange d'un soutien en
faveur de l'indépendance de l'azawad
qu'est ce que vous en pensez
je pense qu on se rejoint sur
l'essentiel c'est à dire on ne sait pas
lire
on ne sait pas lire nos même qu'on ne
sait pas lire le conflit et mais nie
tout conflit afghan et même d'un certain
point de vue le conflit syrien même si
sa nature est totalement différente mais
je dis que ce n'est pas en raisonnant en
terme d'alliance ou au contraire de
bannissement de telle ou telle
organisation qu'on progressera
il faut apprendre il faut apprendre à
lire la réalité sociale c'est ce que je
disais tout à l'heure à propos de mon
livre c'est à dire le monde est porté
par ces dynamiques sociales qui vont
très vite qui court beaucoup plus vite
que le politique et qui peuvent faire
des catastrophes
si on ne les institutionnalise pas à
temps alors parlons il nous reste
quelques minutes par l'ondé de des états
unis on va voir si là aussi les
questions sociales peuvent changer la
donne on est à huit semaines de
l'élection présidentielle il ya quelques
mois beaucoup d'observateurs voyaient
trump réélu c'était quasiment fait
malgré ces coups d'éclat les résultats
économiques étaient plutôt au rendez
vous entre temps il ya eu l'épidémie de
covin plus de 190 mille morts des
mensonges des propos plutôt confus
contradictoires c'est plié selon vous
cette fois dans l'autre sens trump ne
peut pas être
élu avec cette crise qu vide où il faut
toujours faire attention avec les
élections américaines
donc je pense pas que l'on puisse
sérieusement faire un pronostic
et encore moins décidé aujourd'hui qui
sera le vainqueur je me garderai bien de
le faire
est ce que cette fois d'avoir un petit
peu réduit alors c'est une surprise
il vous parler de dynamique sociale y en
a il y a eu le meurtre de george floyd
qui a provoqué une très forte
mobilisation
une prise de conscience politique dans
les minorités aux états unis qui
d'habitude s'abstiennent et ne vote pas
il semblerait que cette mobilisation
espérée sur la base de ce drame ne soit
pas aussi forte qu'on laisse conter on
ne sait pas mais continuons dans la
lecture sociale
trump c'est quelqu'un de bizarre mais
c'est quelqu'un qui a aussi une base
sociale et la base sociale de truc c'est
cette classe moyenne qui se sent
doublement menacée je mets des
guillemets à menacer menacé d'une part
par la montée des minorités le sentiment
qu'ils vont devenir minoritaire chez eux
depuis dix ans dans une fois des
guillemets est menacé par une
mondialisation dont ils s'aperçoivent
ils ont raison là sur ce point qu'elle
ne leur est pas favorable qu'ils seront
était plutôt victime d'un
appauvrissement relatif
et tout ceci effectivement d'un
carburant extraordinaire à la rhétorique
truc bienne qui du coup lorsqu'elle est
excessive rencontre la tante de cette
partie de la société
merci infiniment bertrand badie pour cet
éclairage international sur différents
points merci d'avoir joué le jeu je
rappelle le titre du livre du collectif
regards auquel vous avez participé
dessine moi un pangolin qu'on voit
derrière moi livre dans lequel on
retrouve aussi dominique méda catherine
tricot pierre jacqmin qu'on connaît bien
sur public sénat je rappelle aussi inter
socialité le monde n'est plus
géopolitique c'est du livre coup que
vous publiez le 1er octobre prochain
merci infiniment fin de cette émission